Thanks to my diet of tacos and skittles, my
weight constantly fluctuates, which is yet
another thing I have in common with the kilogram.
Hey killer grams -- which is what I call my
grandma when she’s lookin’ fly -- Jules
here for DNews! How much does a kilogram weigh?
Well...it’s a kilogram, right? But how do
we know how much that is? Maybe a better answer
is: 1000 grams. A gram was originally defined
as the mass of one cubic centimeter of water
at the melting point of ice, and well, that’s
something we can actually measure, rather
than some ephemeral idea of “a kilogram”.
So, now we can say “a kilogram is 1000 cubic
centimeters of water at the melting point
of ice3”. That’s almost dead on accurate,
but that’s not how much a kilogram weighs.
The real answer is that a kilogram is defined
by the weight of one single object in the
entire universe: Le Grand K, or “the Big
K”.
On the outskirts of Paris, in the basement
of the International Bureau of Weights and
Measures, is an environmentally controlled,
impenetrable safe, in which is the official
definition of the kilogram4. It is called
the International Prototype of the Kilogram
or IPK4,. It is a cylindrical piece of metal,
a platinum alloy to be specific, about the
size of a film canister or a golf ball, and
it weighs exactly one kilogram4. And there’s
no way it can’t, because the official metric
definition of a kilogram is equal to whatever
Le Grand K weighs. So if you sneak into the
Pavillion De Breteuil where it’s kept, and
shave one gram off the top, every single “formerly”
one-kilogram weight in the world will now
officially be one gram heavier than a kilogram.
I cannot stress this enough: the entire world’s
scientific understanding of what a kilogram
is, is based on the exact weight of a physical
object stored in a French basement. And it’s
been this way since 1889.
Now, that’s not to say that the IPK isn’t
a fairly reliable source. It is made up of
90% platinum and 10% iridium10, making it
super hard, resistant to oxidation, nearly
twice as dense as lead, and not very susceptible
to magnets. There are a number of exact copies
all around the world to allow for comparison
and calibration.
Now, it's great that they’re going to such
lengths to make sure that nothing happens
to the IPK, because if something were to happen
to it, science would change -- mostly physics.
Think about how often we use the kilogram,
and how much of physics is built on itself.
Take, for example, the newton, which is defined
by the amount of force necessary to move a
kilogram at one meter per second squared.
Then, take the pascal, which is defined as
one newton per square meter, or one kilogram
per meter per second squared. The kilogram
is a base SI unit, so it affects any measurement
that uses mass in kilograms.
And that’s a really bad precedent. Already,
despite every precaution, the IPK is changing.
Since 1889 there have only been two other
verifications of its weight, in 194817 and
1989. What they found is that the Le Grand
K has lost a petit amount of weight. Roughly
50 micrograms, or 50 billionths of a kilogram.
Worse yet, scientists don’t know why that’s
happening 17. So, does this change in mass
means that now all our calculations have to
be redone?
Of course not, but it did force the people
who make those sorts of decisions, The General
Conference on Weights and Measures, to try
and figure out a better system of defining
the kilogram, rather than something you can
accidentally lose in the washing machine.
In 2011, they generally agreed to redefine
the kilogram based on Planck’s constant.
Planck’s constant is a number representing
the relationship between the energy of a particle
and its frequency. You don’t really have
to understand how that works, except that
it never changes, and it relates to energy.
That’s useful, because we can then relate
energy to mass thanks to Einstein’s E=mc2
equation. This means we can define mass, and
therefore, the kilogram, using a constant
figure.
But the Conference on Weights and Measures
decided to postpone the decision to make that
change until 2014, and in 2014 they postponed
it to 2018. Which means that if you’re having
trouble losing weight, you still have a year
or two to fly to France and stick a piece
of gum on the Grand K. A heavier kilogram
means a smaller you!
If you've been a subscriber of DNews for a
while, you might've seen some of our recent
VR videos. It's a completely new way to tell
stories, learn and experience the world, and
we just launched a brand new channel called
Seeker VR. You can view the videos in 360º
from your phone or computer. Click now to
watch, or visit the first link in the description.
And make sure you subscribe to Seeker VR.
So now you know how much a kilogram really
weighs, but how long is a second, really?
We have a video all about that here.
So what do you prefer, kilograms or pounds?
Let us know down below in the comments and
keep coming back here for more DNews every
day of the week.